[Music]
they deserve those great surprises
teacher appreciation staff week ongoing
as well as graduation season right
around the corner well we've got a great
unique gifting idea for you
a tribute video montage doesn't cost a
thing if you do it yourself
you can go to the tribute website gives
you easy to follow prompts to select and
collect videos
let your classmates know so they can add
stuff in you'll get a few prompts asking
you what makes your teacher grad or that
special someone in your life so
incredible
and then you can stitch the videos
together add some music
some photos and personalize my life it's
a reminder of
not the basic generic thank you or the
basic
gift that one could give it's truly a
timeless gift
of the sentiment stories and impact that
that teacher has in their life
now if you don't have the time to edit
it together yourself you can of course
hire the team at tribute to put it
together for you
the company has delivered more than
three million tribute messages
to date due to the distancing with
family and friends during the pandemic
the do-it-yourself tributes are free if
you plug in this code all right
it's hero teacher 25 and that's
available for use over the next few
months for
whoever that special hero is in your
life for any occasion that you want to
show your appreciation and gratitude